but what I try to encourage people to do
is to have a breakthrough by finding a
way to do it more simply and even if the
real simple one has a chance of not
working because it's too simple we'll
try it anyway because in trying it
sometimes you'll stumble onto a solution
on why it wouldn't work and now you've
really at a big gain now you have a
simple thing that does work and that's
that's the real the real challenge now
you can always make something work by
adding complexity but you can never make
something affordable by adding
complexity this is really important
topic for entrepreneurs because we tend
to overcomplicate things we tend not to
make things simple we tend to add
complexity to our business or it's not
necessarily needed and this applies to
multiple errors in your business it'll
apply to how you manage your team it
apply to your schedule and apply to your
product design simplicity can help you
in all areas of your business look at
your schedule as an example look at the
things that are booked into your
schedule for the next week how many of
those things are actually going to
contribute significant growth to your
business how can you simplify your
schedule to add more value to what
you're going to be doing today to your
business one of the things I used to do
every day as I walk to my office in the
morning is think about what is the thing
the single thing that I could do today
to add significant value to my business
keep it simple focus on one main thing
and if I get that accomplished my
business is going to grow so my question
the day for you today is what holds you
back from keeping things simple leave it
in the comments below I want to join in
the discussion and hear what's whole
back thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of an espresso